ce mardi en espagne tous les regards
seront braqués sur la capitale et pour
cause le vote qui doit renouveler
l'assemblée législative de la communauté
autonome de madrid a tout du scrutin
explosif d'abord parce que la région est
la plus riche du pays qu'elle représente
20% du pib et qu'elle est dotée de
pouvoirs considérables ensuite parce que
madrid et sa région dirigée par la
droite et épicentre de la première vague
de la pandémie de covin 19 se sont
opposés au gouvernement central sur la
crise sanitaire
preuve des enjeux que revêt ce vote la
présence du premier ministre pedro
sanchez à la tribune aux côtés du
candidat socialiste
madrid ne peut pas continuer à être
divisée elle ne peut pas continuer à
être systématiquement en conflit avec le
gouvernement espagnol est avec les
gouvernements régionaux voisins qu'ils
appartiennent au parti populaire ou au
parti socialiste le chef du gouvernement
c'est que son parti est en mauvaise
posture dans la capitale car la favorite
des sondages c'est elle isabelle diaz
ayuso la présidente de la communauté de
madrid à la chef de l'exécutif de la
région
cette figure montante du parti populaire
le principal parti d'opposition de
droite a fait campagne sur une critique
de la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement central
la jeune femme a d'ailleurs fait de la
communauté de madrid la région de la
plus permissive du pays
en maintenant bars restaurants cinémas
et théâtres ouvert ils m'ont dit tu dois
fermer
tu dois fermer parce que le ministre le
dit et j'ai dit au président du
gouvernement je ne vais pas fermé madrid
parce qu'il n'y a aucune raison parce
que le vote unis du parti populaire est
le seul vaccin efficace contre le
centrisme contre ce radicalisme contre
la ruine contre la confrontation dans
les rues pourtant bien qu actuellement
crédité de 40 % des intentions de vote
isabelle diaz ayew zone pourra sans
doute pas gouverner seul et devra donc
s'allier à vox la formation nationaliste
qui soutient déjà le parti populaire à
la mairie de madrid et dans deux autres
régions les membres de vox ne cache pas
une certaine nostalgie pour le
franquisme
ce qui leur vaut d'être taxé de
fascistes par les radicaux de gauche de
podemos également lancer dans la course
les rouges contre les fascistes le vieil
antagonistes fantômes de la dictature
espagnole s'est même concrétisé durant
la campagne par l'envoi de lettres
contenant des balles des menaces de mort
dont deux ont été adressées à des
candidats